i feel like
i can't say anything about statistics
but i feel like just from my observation
of people i know and just people in
general i find a lot of women finding
solid good relationships in their older
lives around the ages of 50 even 60.
and i like so my mom my parents split up
when i was young she hadn't dated anyone
for ages and then two years ago she's
been with this guy and they've been
proper solid they're like really good
and i've seen that and a lot of my mom's
friends as well they dated when they
were young didn't work out they divorced
they got kids they don't have kids but
they're finding
love and good solid relationships and
security in their older lives and i feel
like
even the way people view age and society
now is changing and i feel like the
older you are is less stigma it's still
a lot of stigma but just at least for me
people i know
50 years only 40 40 is the new 30 and
30's and your 20 in my view and i feel
like
there are so many opportunities to find
love when you're older where they
weren't 10 15 years ago yeah i mean i
think that's from a female perspective
though because as men get older they get
more options because they make more
money typically fair enough so and like
if you if you look at the data off of
dating apps like it kind of drops off
after like 45 for women in general
and um
a lot of times like the girls that do
find love it's because they're being
realistic and they're saying i don't
need the eights nines and tens anymore
so you should say they get humbled with
that kind of thing yeah i think girls
get i mean would you would you guys
agree that like as men like older women
start to get humbler
yeah yeah yes
absolutely it's not even a bad thing
like
they just end up they just realize they
realize
where they're at and like what they need
is growth
they'll go for the guy that isn't as
good looking but has great character
right yeah
whereas
the younger women won't value the
character as much but they'll look at
how does this guy make me feel at this
moment in time
that's what i want oh is that why you
you mentioned feelings the feelings are
like 20 percent and they don't really
matter like in terms of growth they
would realize that i would look right
that makes me i think as homeless gets
closer and closer
they'll start to
compromise on what they wanted rather
than be on the streets when you're
retirement or alone
regarding like elder women um
you know in my experience i think as i
transitioned from like say 12 13
up until you know like being a fully
grown adult
i know it's like the kind of
pre-pubescent
uh
like the pre-pubescent version of me
when looking at say young women say
maybe in their twenties like yourselves
um at that age prepubescent oh i'm just
a sweet kid walking down looking at
looking at a 20 year old
uh 14 15 started getting facial hair now
i'm like a threat
i'm this potential like rapist you know
what i'm saying
great oh great great
my bad excuse me um
but then uh
you know what say if i'm looking at uh
a woman in their 40s or their 50s
at the age of 12 or at the age of 18
they addressed me and looked at me or
communicated with me in the exact same
way they just treated me like
you know whereas the 20 year old girl i
feel as though is just more
she has to protect herself more because
she gets so much more attention
bad good just attention in general
so in in the process of batting away bad
attention
she might be just like
batting at like perhaps a good
well-intended 15 year old that's just
staring or like a well-intended guy that
has the right intentions that's trying
to approach respectfully but she's had
all of this kind of disrespectful
approaches in the past so she's going to
be like no thank you
i don't want to hear it
um
she's also got options
absolutely so like she's absolutely she
doesn't have to
even vet doesn't have to entertain she
doesn't have to entertain it absolutely
because she's got options that she likes
that um she's probably got guys four
guys she's talking to two guys that are
probably a bit serious um she's got
options
so
but with those options as you're
juggling i feel like the more balls
you're juggling
the more stressed you become and the
more difficult it is to make a decision
and commit to one particular person men
and women are different sure they are of
course there so what you may find
stressful and
um
like multitasking for example you may
see that men are not as great as
as women are yeah for those men out
there that can talk to four or five
different girls all at the same time
i think most i think most guys yeah
yeah no i mean no it's a it's a small
percentage of guys that can is what i
mean
it's 20 or less i would argue probably
like five to five to ten percent of guys
actually can juggle and have the
opportunity to juggle multiple women
yeah i don't know how you do it honestly
i choose a stressful life
but um yeah but i don't think they got
time
it's
unemployed no it's not even time for me
that's why it's not even that they're
unemployed it's that guys girls make
themselves very available to guys of a
certain status and caliber and good
looking absolutely so if a girl is
really attracted to a guy she's going to
jump through freaking hoops
off the top of your head think of a
story of a girl
that was jumping through hoops to get to
a guy that
did not give a [ __ ] about her at all
and so it's not even that time consuming
for those guys because he cannot text
her back for two days and she'll still
be there at 1am when he needs her
so it's like it's like he doesn't have
to manage their relationship because
she's she's down bad
that's sad i think it's um it's
difficult though like when you're
dealing with this kind of dynamic
um
i think a lot of people kind of get
confused i think a lot of young women
they're like why can't i get the ten if
he'll like say if he'll have sex with me
he'll take me out on dates i don't get
it why like who the girl or the guy yeah
the girl the girl the girl is confused
why the guy will well we'll like yeah
exactly i think a lot of women there's a
difference between relationship
attention and sexual attention
absolutely a guy will
sleep with if a guy hasn't slept with
someone in a while and he's nine he
literally might sleep with four because
she's there and like i've heard guys say
things like it's better than my hand
about about a woman and and if you bat
too high you're you're literally the
girl that's the the person that says
like
you're literally just better than his
hand that's how he feels
and do you think women are able to kind
of make that differentiation between
sexual attention and
like roma like genuine romantic i think
girls
honestly in my experience yeah they we
just ignore the signs
like like it's like girls you could say
like your friends can sit her down and
say look this man does not care about
you
he is only using you for sex like he
does not want you in any way shape or
form and she'll say but he was so nice
to me when he talked to me at 2
you don't a.m
he's different around me
but it's like like the writing will be
on the wall but you just can't
you can't it's like because we operate
on our emotions yeah i feel like some
girls i don't want to say that the
delusional but like i feel like
again with
i don't yeah again i don't know if it's
they feel like that if it's in that
moment like like you said oh like i
don't know he makes me feel different at
2am like i don't know maybe
she hasn't
i don't know i think it goes back to
like feelings
do you know what i mean i feel like
she's she's thinking i feel like she's
thinking more of him than
of herself yeah yeah like i don't know
it's just well actually i could tell you
there's there's a um a chemical that
women release when they orgasm
no i'm serious so and it bonds you to
the guy in a way that like he's not
bonded to you
and so if a guy if a guy have you how
many times have you heard the word
dykmatized oh yeah yeah yeah and that's
why it's because we're releasing a
chemical that they don't release
so men they bond you through loyalty and
like quality time
and so a girl can sleep with a guy have
the best sex of her life and like she's
attached where the man is like oh that
was better than my hand
[ __ ]
ish have you ever had a girl that's just
obsessed with you yeah
did she
did she jump through the hoop what did
you do
what did she do she made herself
available
yes yeah yeah i'm
yeah
i can't even talk about that on the
stream still is she watching
who knows she's still obsessed
no no no we had to yeah that one loose